I'm not trying to sit here and advocate
for men to run around and [ __ ] a bunch
of women I'm not saying that no but I'm
not no no no no I'm not what I'm
actually trying to do is describe the
Baseline unfortunate realities of human
dynamics and and I'm trying to explain
now to the world that any woman can get
a man who will not cheat on her if she's
prepared to sacrifice a bunch of other
things perhaps right in the olden days
it was different the world was a
different place it was a completely
different place and it was better now
it's all [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up on
every level and Men especially the high
status men most of them have struggled
so hard to become High status they've
been through so much [ __ ] to get where
they are it's like telling him if you
climb this mountain you can go to a
candy store and he climbs to the top of
the mountain and the second he's in the
candy store after one piece of candy
that [ __ ] is saying no no more candy
he's like no I just climb this mountain
I just got rich I just went through XYZ
I finally got here I'm finally the candy
store now you're telling me I can only
have one piece of candy okay